هنا مركز الزلزال هنا كهرمان مرعش حيث
الانقاض حبلى بالقتله والعالقين هنا انقاذ
وانتظار وكثير من البكاء
وفي المشهد ستيني ينتظر ولاده ابنه من فم
الموت
ابني هنا وعائلته مكونه من سته اشخاص
اخرجوا شخصا واحدا فقط على قيد الحياه
والاعمال مستمره لانقاذهم ولا معلومات
عنهم حتى الان
وفي هذا الحي سوريون هربوا من ويلات الحرب
قبل سنوات هربوا من الموت الى موت اخر
والله ان ثلاثه اشخاص تحت الانقاذ صار لنا
شي يومين لسه ما طلعنا منهم اي خبر او اي
نتيجه منهم في كهرمان مرعش اختلطت الدماء
تحت انقاض اكثر من 940 بنايه سويت بالارض
تمر ساعات والايام وتتضاءل فرص نجاه
العالقين وفي الذاكره صور لاحبه حجم
الكارثه فاق زلزال مرمره عام 99 والصوره
كافيه واصدقوا انباء وفي الصوره ايضا يمكن
نقل اعداد الموتى والجرحى والمصابين
والدمار والدموع لكن وحدها رائحه الموت
على امتداد 10 ولايات لا يمكن نقلها
العربيه كهرمان مرعش